here's a peek at what guests had to say
after the show we're on the Internet
representative Ellison would you be
willing to support congressional term
limits even though it would shorten your
career I will
I was support congressional term limits
if lobbyists agreed to two congressional
term limits if journalists do if the
stay out of lobbyists have limits well
they don't see that's the point
I mean you when people talk about term
limits so that when ways a Congress oh
look look right I come up every two
years people can send me home whenever
they feel like it and but term limits
basically stop the public from being
able to control the one person who they
have the right to vote for I mean people
have to leave I don't believe in term
limits what I do believe it is is
stopping this gerrymandering oh I
believe in that too I agree
I mean that's just ridiculous you know
the old saying I mean I'm not the first
one to say it but you know it's like the
district's picked the voters instead of
the voters picking yeah congressman we
need a national bipartisan or
nonpartisan redistricting that's
something we gotta fight for it okay
look so there's a lot of things that we
thought we could never get but we got
them so let's fight for you do it
there's limits you have the natural life
expectancy of people tell that to John
Dingell actually go the opposite
direction we're talking about making the
terms longer I mean these guys have to
run every two years the constant
pressure to raise money you before with
four years in the house eight years in
this Senate I think that would actually
be better but give them a chance to do
good policy they working for Congress
all right there has a lot of merit but I
tell you what we what if we just said
you cannot donate more than a hundred
dollars that was good
so what what we made you know what if we
banned election advertising as as we do
in Britain yeah on the traps are there
any debate over gerrymandering because
exactly wordplay
it's called redistricting right there's
no consciousness whatsoever and the
grocery that this is an appalling kind
of disease there's a lot of
consciousness that it's appalling right
the problem is we just have got to do
something about it and that means see we
have a state by state by state system we
don't have an election we have fifty
different elections yeah and so that
system is messed up me and a guy named
mark Pocan have a constitutional
amendment to guarantee the right to vote
see a Congress he is and he's from
Wisconsin just a guy me and a guy what
can he do he's a good guy yeah where she
from with Madison Wisconsin okay and
we're our Democrat good Democrat yep but
the point is this will help Republicans
to because right now there really is no
constitutional right to vote what there
is is a constitutional right to not be
discriminated against on the basis of
your race or something like that but if
we have an affirmative right to vote
then the burden would shift over to
people who want to suppress the vote
would say voter ID or or purging schemes
or things like that we need to say that
the people have a right to vote have
their right the vote counted I think
that would make a lot of difference but
he raised the point about raising money
yeah I mean we're doing our show we're
gonna take our show to Washington in
September okay I've been there before
doing our shows if you talk to people in
Congress and ask them you know what is
the worst part of your job they will all
say the same thing pretending not to be
gay
but right after that they will say
raising that I mean how many hours okay
awful do you have to spend you know call
it's just demeaning time-consuming
counterproductive it's bad on both sides
of the phone right nobody likes it right
it's right the guy in the other ring
doesn't like being hit on for money
either absolutely not and the we need to
just say cease and desist you know 100
dollars uh you know the right way to go
okay here's a question for the professor
given the current negotiations between
Israel and Palestine you believe a
two-state solution is possible um well
you hope that's the only way peace is
ever going to happen actually but the
issue has just been raised about whether
or not the Palestinians are prepared to
recognize a definition of Israel as a
Jewish state in fact Yasser Arafat did
recognize that actually not in a formal
way there but the problem now is raised
what then happens psychologically to
Arab Israelis who do actually suffer a
lot of discrimination my view is that
it's it's not objectively it shouldn't
be an obstacle but really my Israeli
friends shouldn't it shouldn't be a
deal-breaker if everything else is in
place God willing it would be in place
for the basis of a peace settlement you
know but but it's interesting really how
something that seems to be so
philosophical and psychological should
suddenly be a stumbling block
so Netanyahu of course is being accused
of actually seeking stumbling blocks I
don't think that's true I actually don't
think that's true I think he would light
you know his divided a part of him is
the regular political pragmatist half of
them is I think spooked by Ariel Sharon
having been on the verge of making a
peace settlement but you know two states
Palestinian state for Palestinians a
Jewish state for in Israel it's the only
conceivable way there will ever be peace
but I can't say I'm exactly Pollyanna
about it myself and you I mean your
history of the Jews is amazing only like
only goes up to 1492 yeah that was when
Jews were expelled yeah sure yeah the
sequel I'm writing
ends tonight with us so hey you're
somewhat Irish bill right yes my mother
the good bit yeah I know if your mother
your mother's Jewish my mother was
Jewish welcome to the bagel club that
makes you a whole you know the whole
sense I've heard that all right first of
all I was raised Catholic first of all I
hate all village I was raised a lot of
Jews do so but also this idea I've heard
all my life you know if your mother's
Jewish you're Jewish that's a Roman law
do we go by other Roman laws can I make
myself throw up in the sanatorium I mean
it is not ridiculous but I know you
think I mean I read it in the book that
you say you think of all the peoples in
the world
maybe the Jews have suffered the most no
I don't think that I think actually I
didn't I think no no I mean I think
actually what that you know what is
extraordinary if you grow up as a kind
of baby historian and the 50s and 60s
when you actually thought that the
problems that will destroy the world
would be ideology would be the Cold War
be nuclear weapons what you did not
think I mean my history teacher said to
me well boys it was just boys whatever
else we don't know about the rest of the
20th century it's for sure that
organized religion and nationalism will
no longer be a problem not of what we've
gone through in the last war so much for
the prophetic powers of history right
that the great issue apart in Greenland
literally I'm serious you know the death
of the planet is how peoples have
different beliefs you know it can manage
to share the same living space without
the obligation to exterminate each other
a hundred thousand people have died in
Syria over that and elsewhere where if
you look the Jews have experienced that
problem not necessarily more seriously
than gypsies or Armenians but more
relentlessly right and I've written
about it and you know so and they've
survived by not having armies being
uprooted from territory just really
safeguarding the way they tell our own
story and well I don't know and until
now they got a kick-ass army yeah which
they ain't giving up and I'm well
moving out that's true okay Sheila how
many bankers and top executives are you
personally aware of that evaded jail
time by paying fines with other people's
parenthesis shareholders money well
probably most of them actually had
really been very few yeah they're been
very well they're the prosecution's when
they've heard of Ben Lehman at the lower
level the originator level the higher
level of folks know if there have been
fines had generally been paid by the
corporation she has a problem do you
think anybody should have gone to jail
look there was a massive fraud prior to
the crisis and again it was the
origination level but you've got to
assume as bad as it was that people
higher up knew it was going about
whether it was criminal or whether there
should be more civil prosecutions I
personally think that just going after
people's personal pock but you know some
of these Wall Street guys taking their
money's worse than sending them to jail
so you know maybe that's but you should
be the strategy but no there hasn't been
enough and it's bad because it doesn't
change behavior people you know there's
a lot of concern about why is taking
their money worst and sending them to
jail well I was joking but maybe not
because I think money is very very moral
them okay uh what do you have next ro
who are you working on who's gonna be
facing your crazy camera next time
maybe you maybe their lips to God's ear
thank you very much everybody Real Time
with Bill Maher ask villainous guests
your questions right after the show at
hbo.com or on Twitter